well new this morning in the Las Vegas
metro area vehicle thefts are up nearly
20 percent compared to last year just in
the month of October alone officers
investigated
935 reports of car thefts Joshua peguero
Joins us live now after speaking with a
couple of people who had their cars
stolen in the valley Joshua tell us what
we can do to protect ourselves
hello so good morning one way you can
protect yourself expertise is by making
sure that when you leave your vehicle
you leave with the car door unlocked and
it was a car door unlocked excuse me and
with the number of thefts On The Rise
it's a comment on you than ever before
to protect your vehicle data share about
police shows last year Nevada the number
one stolen vehicle was the 2004
Chevrolet pickup next on that list was a
2006 Ford pickup followed by the 2000
Honda Civic we spoke to two people who
were visiting Las Vegas from out of town
and had their Ford pickups stolen both
were parked at hotels in the valley when
someone broke in
it was a sinking gut feeling that now
I'm out now only all my tools for my
livelihood and all of our other personal
effects are on the truck but now I'm
also out this truck that's somewhere off
in Las Vegas getting driven around
getting stripped or whatever honestly
maybe 10 minutes by the time we went an
elevator up and then he went back down
the truck was gone
now both immediately filed police
reports Sherry Webster was the only
person of those two that was able to get
her vehicle back coming up at 6 30
you'll hear from experts and get tips on
how you could protect yourself and your
vehicle reporting live near Las Vegas
Boulevard Joshua figuero eight news now
back to Union Studio